good evening everyone each day brings
another report of dramatic change in the
news media in the last 24 hours alone
the New York Times said it was going to
get smaller The Wall Street Journal said
they're going to put print ads in the
front page the blogosphere
is bigger and bigger and everyone is
trying to figure out what this all means
i'm nancy bass widen i am the wife of
Democrat Senator Ron Wyden of Oregon I
am also the owner of the strand
bookstore along with my dad
fred bass for a little bit of history
about the store it was founded by my
grandfather in 1927 in an area in New
York City around the corner it was known
as book Row this area existed from about
the 1890s until the 1960s at its height
there were 48 book stores today the
strand is the sole survivor from those
days I am proud with so many changes
afoot in the reading business that we at
the Strand have said focused on on what
we've done for the last 80 years making
it easy to buy and read good books we
also continue to reach out to the
community with our evening book series
and that's why I thought you'd enjoy
hearing from Eric's Bullard his new book
lapdogs is about the press and President
Bush this is generating a real debate
about the future of media it's an
important topic and we're glad to give
you the chance to weigh in on the
spirited debate tonight Eric will
discuss his book he'll be happy to take
questions just be sure to stand up and
wait for us to give you the mic so that
we can we can hear you Eric will stick
around afterwards to personalize copies
of his book and I'll feel free we have
wine available and water and available
in the back I want to especially thank
c-span for its commitment toward
unfiltered unvarnished broadcasting you
are we are need of this now more than
ever since
Thank You Stan so please welcome
award-winning journalist Eric ball art
to the Strand thank you thank you very
much thanks for having me it's honored
to be the Strand it's honored to be on
c-span my folks are proud I'm sure
honestly it's really when you're on
c-span that's that's sort of it's a
great achievement I mean compared to
what's going on and the rest of the
cable and network news shows it is
really refreshing so I want to talk
about lapdogs I want to talk about the
press I want to talk about the what I
see is some of the unfortunate trends
and some of the real failings of the
mainstream media particularly in the
last five or six years so I'll tell you
a little bit about other book came to be
and then we'll talk about the the more
meaty stuff the book the book is not a
name-calling book the book is not it's
important it's important to
differentiate sort of the liberal
critique of the mainstream media and the
conservative critique of the mainstream
media the conservative critique comes
from most often from people who actually
despise the press and don't want the
press to be around and they want to
dismantle the press and we see that it's
becoming increasingly apparent
particularly on the conservative
blogosphere the rhetoric we've seen with
the New York Times attacking the New
York Times as treasonous in the last
couple weeks that's really that's really
how they feel and I think it just
bubbled up with the recent reporting on
the banking on the Terrorism banking
stories they don't understand journalism
and I don't think they like Turtle ism I
think they wanted to sort of out of the
way sort of unfettered access to sort of
the story they wanted so the liberal
critique of the media I think it's much
different I think it's much more factual
I know it's marked fracture
and it comes from people who respect
journalism and want it to be better and
more responsible and want it to grow and
prosper
so lapdogs like most as I think the
liberal critique of the press is not a
not a hateful critique it's not a
name-calling critique I don't think
journalists are treasonous or
unpatriotic or anything like that I do
however think there's something
seriously wrong with how the press and
the Beltway press has been covering the
bush White House when the book came
about the book I started the book just
over a year ago thirteen months ago and
it's been in stores since May and for
folks who know publishing that's a
pretty remarkable turnaround and I
credit my publisher for doing that
it's normally I finished writing in
March there are things in the book from
March of 2006 and it was in stores in
May normally when you're done writing
you wait nine or ten months and
eventually your book arrives buttoned
that because when I when I signed the
contract it was for 80,000 words and I'd
never written anything longer than
really three or four thousand words at
salon in Rolling Stone and I was nervous
because it was my first book and I
wasn't sure if I was going to have
enough material to fill you know 80,000
words by December I'd 140 thousand words
which I laughed off about 40 during
January locked in my office but the
point is there was way too much stuff
and the distressing part that meant
there was sort of way too much bad
journalism to write about and dissect
and document so in a way writing the
book was as a writer is exhilarating
because you have all is sort of shooting
fish in a barrel I mean there was so
much to talk about the Downing Street
memo there was the Swift Boat Veterans
for truth there was the war I mean I'd
wrote three separate chapters on the
media coverage to the run-up to the war
the war itself and the aftermath we had
Bush in the National Guard and so there
was a lot to cover and I wish there
wasn't so much to cover
I wish there wasn't so much
what I consider to really do to be just
bad journalism and and people
what's distressing is I think it's
people to know better and we'll talk
about some of the examples and we'll see
I don't know how you look at some of
these examples and not see how people of
journalists in Washington in the Beltway
they know better and and and they're
just not they're just not reporting the
way they should be reporting basically
the gist of the book is there's been a
titanic shift in way the press has
covered the Bush White House and how it
covered the previous Democratic White
House and and too often I think
reporters have been sort of afraid of
the facts and the consequences of
reporting them and that that is sort of
translated into this sort of shrieking
double standard four months into Bill
Clinton's presidency if you remember
when he came from Arkansas he came with
a lot of outside people they stumbled
very badly in the beginning they took
him forever to find an attorney general
if you remember that very bumpy
transition in the Washington Post in
April of 93 wrote this big feature
called and the headline was another
failed presidency question mark and it
was very mocking in tone and at that
point Bush Clinton was at 43% and the
job approval rating and for the post
that signaled a colossal failure and
it's signaled that maybe Clinton like
Bush Senior was going to be another
failed presidency if you when I wrote
the book in March of 2006 and George
Bush at that point was at approximately
36 or 37 percent job approval rating six
years in office the Washington Post had
never described the Bush presidency as a
failed presidency had never even raised
the question to this day that's really
not a question that's talked about in
Washington you have a completely failed
war in Iraq you have up and down sort of
domestic and foreign failures you have a
historically unpopular two-term
President Bush in a couple months will
break Richard Nixon's modern-day record
for most months under 40%
job approval rating and and but he's not
a failed presidency I mean you almost
never hear that debate you certainly
don't hear it on the talk shows and
things like that but that's sort of the
the sort of shrieking double standard
and and what I do in my book is I talk a
lot about specifics and I talk about a
lot about individual stories and I tried
to document or put as many numbers and
facts together to give people a
perspective so I looked at the coverage
of the the Valerie Plame investigation
because clearly was scooter libby being
indicted he was the first I think
senior sitting senior aide to be
indicted while serving the President and
something like 150 years it was obvious
it's clearly the most serious criminal
investigation of the Bush administration
it's taken up untold amount of time and
their money and I think clearly
distracted the Bush administration so I
so right after scooty Liberty was
indicted I went and I looked to see what
the network coverage was and
specifically the news magazines the sort
of signature 60 minutes 60 minutes to
primetime live Dateline and things like
that in two years from September of 203
when the story broke that the White
House had been sort of purposely leaking
Valerie Plame's identity until the time
scooter libby was indicted that's two
years if you add up all the broadcast
that's over 400 broadcasts of those
network news shows there was not one
segment on the Valerie Plame
investigation in two years on any of
those shows if you then multiply number
of segments obviously 60 minutes usually
does three segments a night a lot of the
others do the same it's over 700
segments on the network news magazines
and not one if anyone bothered to do a
single report on the Valerie Plame
investigation and to me you know that
really puts into stark contrast I think
this double standard and and you would
think coming off the Clinton years when
it was sort of non-stop that
investigation something something
happened
serve at the stroke of midnight on
Inauguration Day 2001 where there was
this massive shift in thinking I looked
at the Nightline coverage of the Valerie
Plame clearly it's on a lot more often
every night on ABC the premiere news
telecast in two years they had done
three segments on valerie plame they
aired hunt hundreds of episodes through
the year three on valerie plame one was
really about one was more of a first
amendment debate should journalists be
subpoenaed should journalists go to jail
for not revealing their sources they
really did two serious reports on the
Valerie Plame investigation I went back
I looked at the first two years of
whitewater when I was strictly a real
estate deal had nothing to do with Paula
Jones it was this impossible to follow
convoluted real estate transaction
Nightline did 19 episodes the first two
years on whitewater as a real estate
deal
those those double standards I think are
really sort of the telltale sign of what
we've seen in terms of the in terms of
this timidity and and the double
standard it didn't start in 2004 or 2003
I mean if you go back to the 2000
campaign with poor Al Gore I mean that
was sort of the mother of all double
standards in terms of how the press was
covered gore gore was not it's an
understatement to say Gore was was
portrayed as an exaggerator I mean he
was really portrayed quite often on the
cable shows as a psychopath as a chronic
liar who really not only did not know
who he was but was incapable of telling
truth I mean that is not an exaggeration
in terms of how al gore was portrayed
for month after month how was George
Bush portrayed in 2000 George Bush was
authentic George Bush didn't care about
polls George Bush was the person
Americans wanted to have a beer with
remember this was there was no precedent
for coming up with a standard of who
Americans wanted to vote for based on
who they want to have a
year with it was completely fabricated
conventional wisdom that Chris Matthews
and Brian Williams and the rest came up
with no one ever did any polling no one
even try to assemble anecdotal evidence
they did not like Al Gore they like
George Bush therefore they created the
narrative and and so and it's also
important to put in context once Bush
was elected in terms of the press
coverage there was there was a sort of
sort of a massive pushback against the
press
I mean Bush clearly came in with an
agenda in terms of how to deal with the
press and how not to deal with the press
he essentially walked away from press
conferences I mean the first term he had
the fewest of any modern president he
really you know by hiring someone like
scott mcclellan to be his press
representative someone who is really you
know very inarticulate clearly was not
in the loop like some of the previous
press secretaries the administration I
think was sending a signal that we don't
really take you seriously you know they
really walked away from the idea that
the press was the public's
representative in Washington and ecard
for his you know it's former chief of
staff famously called
the press just another special interest
group seeking access in Washington that
really broke was you know almost a
century old tradition in terms of a
modern press government relationship and
that really that wasn't that if I one of
the dangers with the book was every page
and think just imagine what would have
happened during Clinton because it comes
it becomes tiresome but you do have to
think what if the Clinton administration
had declared war on the press the way
the Bush has the way they just sort of
arrogantly brushed them off it would
have been it would have been world war 3
in that press room I mean and and we're
not talking when you were talking about
paying pundits like Armstrong Williams
like the administration oh it's hard to
conceive where they sort of
it got to the point when they were
paying Armstrong Williams was letting
people like Jeff Gannon into the White
House press office former male escort
who had absolutely no legitimate press
credentials and did not work for
legitimate news organizations let it was
sort of waved him in without having to
you know submit to an FBI background
like every other reporter in Washington
I mean it was almost by 2005 they sort
of run out of ways to humiliate the
press I mean we're going to pay pundits
we're going to we're going to have
amateurs in the in the White House we're
going to call them just another special
interest group and yet so there's this
huge pushback from the Republican
administration and they're clearly
riding on the conservative war on the
press that's been going on for three
decades so you have this administration
that that's telling the press we don't
care about you you don't matter and you
have the right wing attacks and what
develops is this sort of bizarre
love-hate relationship in that the
Republican White House hates the press
and the press falls in love with the
Republican White House and and and they
and they've done it they've done it
consistently throughout the
administration and it doesn't it wasn't
about 9/11 I don't think and I don't
think it was about the war in Iraq
people say well naturally there was sort
of this patriotic fervor and the press
is going to retreat and because it
doesn't want to seem anti-american and
it doesn't want to seem like it's
helping terrorists and things like that
but really if you look at the press
coverage I mean I started the book the
first chapter was Bush's
coverage in 2005 because I think that's
when he got his most timid and most
pleasing press coverage I mean that was
obviously four years after 9/11 and two
years after the invasion so I don't
think it can just be explained away by
the sort of the extraordinary foreign
policy events that occurred but again
we've just seen it sort of over and over
and I want to talk about two recent
examples that happened after the book
and on you know sort of unfortunately I
think things have only gotten worse in
the last few months when we look at the
the bush bounce remember in May after
Kyle was murdered
and a couple other who were supposed to
be these great events that were going to
boost the Bush administration I remember
turning on CNN and Anderson Cooper's
they were running a segment on what was
going to happen there was going to be
this Bush bounce made a lot of experts
talking I can't remember in previous
administrations when it was news that
the president might soon become popular
and that that was that was that was
something that should be discussed at
length
because these things happen and he might
become popular although it wasn't of
course CNN CNN being couch it that way
because according to CNN and everyone
else Bush is popular but the truth was
there were there sort of wondering you
know was Bush going to get this bounce
and it was the that was a conventional
wisdom for several weeks I mean all the
cable talk shows we're talking we're
talking about this bounces that was
going to come it never materialized it
absolutely never materialized in fact
the last Bush poll last Fox poll Bush
had gone up to 41 and now he's down to
down back to 36% again he has he is and
historically unpopular president and the
the press just refuses to talk about it
and refuses to put it into context if
you go back to Bush's re-election what
was the mantra after he beat John Kerry
by three points to his Amanda he had a
mandate he won Bush's re-election in 204
was the most narrow re-election win by
sitting president since Woodrow Wilson
in 1916 and I take up an entire page in
the book with just the headlines and and
the talk-show chatter about this
sweeping mandate and again going back to
you know what would happen during
Clinton when in 96 when when Clinton was
re-elected in he won by ninety seven
electoral votes much more than than Bush
did the front page of the New York Times
the next day front page analysis was
they made a point of noting that Clinton
had not won a mandate
for his reelection so it's hard to it's
hard to it's hard to put those two
things together they don't add up and
clearly Bush has has gotten a wonderful
benefit of the doubt time and time again
and if what's important about Bush's
unpopularity and the Press's refusal
really to deal with it the bigger point
is you know I think the American people
have been way ahead of the press on
Bush's popularity as well as Iraq I
think if you look at the polls I think
most Americans really came to the
conclusion probably twelve or sixteen
months ago that Iraq was unwinnable that
there was not much the United States
could do and that they needed to start
thinking about bringing troops home and
in terms of Bush I think the fact that
he got absolutely no bounce after you
know we read all about how he was going
to I think it shows the American people
have essentially closed the book on
Bush's presidency I mean unless there is
a truly catastrophic event I don't think
they're going to give him another look
and I think this is what Bush's second
term is going to be and again it's
historically unpopular by any by any
measure but the press won't really talk
about that they keep they keep they keep
this narrative alive like he just needs
one more good break and he can get over
40 percent and you know it can be back
at 50 percent I don't think it's true
and that there's nothing to indicate
that he'll ever be at 45 percent
barring any sort of a catastrophic event
but again the press really doesn't talk
about that and and I was talking about
the troops that's another issue that
came up and it was another instance
where the press really played dumb I
think they just refused to look at the
polls and it was the debate in the
Senate about bringing American troops
home and it was the Republicans went on
the offensive with the cut-and-run
terminology and rhetoric and and their
point was there can be no timetable
being a setting up a timetable would be
capitulating to terrorists and Democrats
going to cut and run Democrats were soft
on national security and and and again
the press essentially we have you know
it's just repeating talking points I
mean that's all it is I mean they talked
about how Republicans were gleeful
watching the Democrats with this trying
to fend off this cut and run the
Democrats were divided Newsweek wrote a
remarkable piece where they talked about
after it was over they talked about
still the Democrats lost a week in the
war over the war talking about the
Senate the debate in the Senate and D
Democrats failed a rack strategy stand
together talk tough and make plans to
leave lined up exactly with the
prescriptions found on DailyKos the
liberal website that sort of the
ultimate insight that sort of the
ultimate Beltway insult which is
Democrats sound like bloggers that's the
ultimate insult problem is if you looked
at the polls it didn't line up
necessarily bloggers aligned up with the
majority of the American people who want
a timetable poll after poll say they
want the troops start coming home what
the Wall Street Journal had a remarkable
poll because they asked the question
specifically if you're voting for a
candidate and one candidate advocates a
specific timetable for bringing troops
home who would you vote for and it was
something like fifty five thirty five
they would vote for the candidate who
was in favor of a timetable that is the
Democratic that is essentially the
Democratic position and the Democrats
were absolutely ridiculed in the in the
Beltway press during the debate over the
troop withdrawal because the culture in
DC even now it amazes me it seems this
sort of if Carl Rolls signs off on a
strategy and the strategy clearly was to
hit Democrats hard on Iraq a sort of cut
and run the the depressed just sort of
assumes it's a work of genius I mean
they still they still hold Karl Rove as
this Machiavellian genius and his
president our president but his you know
he's devising the president he's a
thirty five percent I mean
now how smart are are the policies the
Karl Rove is sort of unveiling I mean
the cut and run rhetoric worked great
inside the beltway but you know are the
Republicans really going to go into the
fall election basically going all-in on
Iraq and you know Joe Scarborough the
reformer right-wing Congressman NBC
talk-show host during that week he he
was one of the few that sort of pointed
out the obvious he said I'm he said I'm
looking at the polls on Iraq he said the
Republican position is a loser
so Joe Scarborough a former Republican
conservative congressman can read the
polls and understand the problems that
Republicans are going to have may have
in the fall but apparently newsrooms
inside the beltway can't make that same
connection or absolutely refused to make
the connection it was it was it was a
really depressing example I think of
again of the press playing dumb because
the Democratic position was not the
position of the liberal bloggers the
Democratic position was the position of
most Americans and they were beat up for
it and they were mocked for it and it
reminded me of the it reminded me of the
Terri Schiavo case from 2005 which I
thought was a real press failing in a
very similar way this was this was this
was presented as a national debate this
was this was presented as a national
controversy there's raging controversy
about right the right-to-die issue and
it was completely hijacked in News
Nightline I think did five at five
nights and two weeks the ABC all the
network news opened with it almost every
night for a week it was it was
absolutely told through the prism of
conservatives religious conservatives
and again just like the cut and run the
press for a week essentially ignored all
the polls and the polls more
overwhelming than the cotton run debate
60 70 80 percent of Americans thought
what Republicans were doing in the Terri
Schiavo case was wrong but for in real
time for a week in two weeks
the
as portrayed that as a home run for as a
home run for Republicans and in
portrayed it as as Democrats being weak
on moral issues on ethical issues and
again you know I remember March 21st of
2000 and 2005 the morning in the morning
ABC News released a poll I think the
number was 67 percent opposed the
Republican intervention in the Terri
Schiavo case that night ABC news when
Peter Jennings was still anchoring
opened with the Terri Schiavo story
first story made no mention of its own
polling showed a vast majority oppose
what Republicans were doing
ABC News did four straight Terri Schiavo
reports at the top of the hour at the
top of the broadcast it never reported
on its own polling data I think that I
think that's probably unprecedented
polls aren't cheap and networks don't do
them on the whim they cost a lot of
money and they cost a lot of time and
ABC wasn't even reporting on his own
polling data LA Times during the first
week of the Terri Schiavo story I
counted 11 stories before they mentioned
any polling data on how Americans felt
it's it's the refusal to put things into
context and again it was sort of like
the mandate I have a whole page in the
book just talking about the press
depicting the Terri Schiavo's story as
this wild debate this raging debate
everyone was debating this right-to-life
issue well there was no debate I mean
80% of Americans agree how can you have
a debate when everyone agrees there was
no debate but depressed the press overly
impressed with Republicans and at the
time I think after the reelection were
feeling very nervous about being
portrayed as liberal being portrayed as
anti religion which they're very
sensitive to and and then just refused
to put the story into context one other
point about the you know being fearful
of anti religion the other thing that
one of the questions is always why why
is this happening and the book the book
unfortunately does not offer the answer
it's more of sort of a brief
sort of an explanation of evidence and I
think anyone who reads it would come to
the obvious conclusion that there's
something drastically wrong here but if
I did if I did have to offer a
suggestion I think it's clearly the fear
of the liberal media charge I think that
has been incredibly helpful to the
Conservatives they've been doing for
over three decades
I think reporters in the Beltway have
they've produced they've gotten is the
real rabbit ears on that charge and they
don't like it and they try to avoid it
and I think it has
I think it has career implications for
anyone who is sort of tagged you know to
caustic towards Republicans or liberal
and things like that so unfortunately I
unfortunately I think through the
crusade on the conservative side has
worked and I think it's produced
extraordinary dividends for them I think
folks on the left on the progressive
side are doing better and and they've
realized this and they're starting to
fight back but again it's you know as I
mentioned in the beginning this is not a
name-calling book and and when lots of
tough questions comes up for her
liberals they the question is do we want
to fight like conservatives fight you
know do we want to write books calling
journalists traitors and godless and
things like that
and and you know it was like the Swift
Boat incident I mean would we do we
really want to win elections by just
smearing veterans I mean it's so but I
but so I don't I mean I don't want to be
part of sort of a jihad against the
press and and pretend that their godless
awful people and they're on the payroll
of the Republican Party because I don't
think that's true but I think
progressives do understand that they
need to deal with this issue because I
mean it almost doesn't matter what your
message is if you're my if your message
can't get through the filter it's it's
not going to do you any good so I think
there is a lot of work to be done and
and the Liberals have to figure out how
to deal with this the rules have to have
to figure out how to make the coherent
argument and they have to figure out how
to sort of break this chain within
Washington because as I said there's
there something sort of seriously wrong
and I mentioned the Swift Boat incident
which for me I wrote a chapter a whole
chapter on it I think was the first
chapter actually wrote and I think I was
so angry still in 2005 that I wanted to
write about it it's not the chapters not
so much a rehash of the whole saga but
really how the press dealt with it and I
think the larger problem within the
Swift Boat story was this new obsession
with balance that the press has not
fairness but balance every all
journalism should be fair all journalism
should be responsible but the issue of
fairness the issue of balance becomes
sort of a he-said she-said and so
particularly during nasty campaigns
journalists feel like their job I think
unfortunately more and more their job is
to report the attack and then get the
denial and then you sort of throw up
your hands and you say we don't we don't
really know what's going on and I think
the Swift Boat Veterans for truth was
the ultimate
sample of that and and and obviously I
think it cost John Kerry the election so
it's an incredibly important issue so I
just want to read part of this and I'm
not even sure if this was in the book
this might have been part of the 40,000
words I get lopped off but it's
important because this this formulation
of balance is not a healthy one and it's
one that I think plays into the
Republicans because they're the one that
often what sort of lob these phony
charges and they're the ones that put
Democrats on the defensive and so they
sort of you know Swift Polk Swift Boat
Veterans for truth I call essentially a
hoax it was just a very expensive dirty
trick and it was it was a charade and
nothing about it was was factual and
nothing about it was honest and nothing
about it was worthy of campaign
reporting but the Republicans are able
to sort of launch these phony attacks
and the press securities around and and
and and and you know it's it's funny
because in 2000 I don't think anyone saw
the Al Gore election Fiasco the Al Gore
exaggeration Gasko coming and I don't
think anyone in 2004 saw the Swift Boat
Veterans for truth Fiasco coming so
something's coming in 2008 obviously so
I think it's important to understand how
these things get off the ground and how
you can best battle them but I want to
just read this part about the Swift Boat
Veterans and how the press dealt with it
once it became clear the press was not
going to stay away from the Swift Boat
claims the second approach would have
been to focus intently on the
allegations to dogged ly determine what
if anything the Swifties were saying was
grounded in truth there was precious
little of that kind of truth-telling
instead reporters fell into the trap of
covering the story as a process one
specifically the press spent too much
time writing about the Swifties
Republican ties who was funding the
group was there any proof the White
House was behind the tax and would Bush
denounce the ad for instance during the
August 22nd taping of Meet the Press
host Tim Russert
bush-cheney spokesman ken mehlman about
the Swifty's focusing almost exclusively
on the question of ties between the
campaign and the Swifties i just want to
talk more about the possible connections
between the Bush campaign and these ads
ad Russert naturally Melman denied there
were any in the televised debate didn't
go anywhere as is his custom Russert was
safely asking the wrong questions where
Ruster could have spent his time doing
was highlighting how swift boat veterans
george mitchell george le changed his
story three times in one month how swift
the al french lied about having
first-hand knowledge about carries medal
about swifty larry Thurlow own bronze
medal citation completely contradicted
the group's claims about enemy gunfire
how swiftly author John O'Neill could
have come clean about who the co-author
was instead Russia refused to raise a
single pointed question about any of the
glaring inconsistency of the swiftie
allegations the press really did not
want to talk about the allegations they
wanted to talk about the process I
continue getting credibly when wrestler
turned to the programs other guests had
divined a spokesperson spokesman for the
Kerry campaign Meet the Press the Meet
the Press host press divine about an
18-year old statement Kerry had made
about his Vietnam service that was
followed up by a question by a 25 year
old statement Kerry made about his
Vietnam service which rested then
followed by asking a 36 year old fact
Kerry got wrong about his previous
Vietnam service the pattern was clear
when wrestler was grilling the
Republicans in the Swifties he wanted to
talk vaguely about process and political
connections not about the facts of the
allegations but when he was grilling a
Democrat Russert wanted to go deep into
the weeds and talk about long ago facts
and any inconsistency Kerry might have
had regarding his combat service in the
eyes of wrestler and so many elite DC
press players it was Kerry who had
explained the specifics of Vietnam not
the Swift Boat Veterans the men making
the phoney allegation and and and and
really again the question was the
balance formula what the press did there
and what cost Kerry so dearly I'm not
letting him off the hook I don't think
the campaign responded all that well and
it could have done a better job but the
press decided
they just sort of threw up their hands
and you know sort of called it the fog
of war we will never know what John
Kerry did in Vietnam and and those were
literally the headline you know USA
Today LA Times it was just a he-said
she-said will never know what john kerry
didn't vietnam but you know the new US
navy knows what john kerry did in
vietnam because he's got military
documents in the swift boat veterans
were never able to challenge a single
fact of his documents but the press is
sort of playing this balance game and I
think being afraid of calling out a you
know standing up to Republican hardball
Republican hoax Republican dirty trick
it really felt to do their job and and
and sort of hid behind the shield of
balance so those are some of the things
that I talked about in lapdogs and those
are some of the things that I think are
discouraging about the current press
discourse and I'm sad to say I think
it's getting worse rather than better
but that doesn't mean there can't be
change and hopefully you know progresses
and folks who are concerned about this
will realize that's going to take you
know a lot of hard work but it's
paramount not only for journalism
because it plays such an important role
in democracy but for a you know just for
political purposes for Democrats to try
to get their message out because right
now they're just not getting a fair
shake from the press thank you
[Applause]
sorry
highly recommend it and before I make my
comments I just want to show you
yesterday's USA Today when they refer to
Bush's tough talk at the summit when it
was really vulgar obscene scatological
which would have gotten them thrown off
radio if he had made the same remarks I
can also give you to various Bush's
authentic them yes
he's amazed plain-spoken yes and I think
another example of the press which is
coming up right now if Lieberman should
go down in on August 8th the press comes
going to say there goes those crazy
Democrats again and it's the press
that's always saying that the Democrats
have to move more to the center when
we're a centrist party never saying that
the Republicans are made up of
right-wing crackpots and the other thing
is what do you think about this was a
comment in a column by David Carr who's
the media I guess correspondent for the
New York Times who referred to Ann
Coulter as one of the most important
political writers of our time because
she sells a lot of books I'd like you to
come what I'd have to see David Carr
cuz he's a smart guy I'm not sure okay
well what Ann Coulter is interesting
because even the press I don't know I
think the press feels I don't think the
press any longer enjoys writing about
her because she's so demented
but but it's hard you know when that
Time magazine put Anna Coulter on the
cover last year after being one of the
most hundred influential people in the
world the very next week they put her on
the cover seven thousand word Valentine
in which they announced the writer
announced he could not find any factual
errors that Ann Coulter had made
and lots of smart people of a dedicated
entire website to documenting those
errors but they came under some pressure
and they said all we had Michael Moore
on the cover so now we're going to have
an Coulter on the cover and that's sort
of it's interesting because Ann Coulter
is she's not on any political scale
she's not you know left right far right
left you know far left there's no I
don't know who you would find on the
left who to counterbalance her so what
I'm saying is she's allowed into the
public debate because she's a
conservative Republican she's she's a
you know conservative firebrand even
though she's nuts but when Michael Moore
who's an award-winning documentary you
know makes news and gets a lot of cover
easy coverage he's sort of he's held up
is the you know the liberal equivalent
of Ann Coulter and which is you know
embarrassing for Michael because he's
not obviously but her presence is just
sort of an insult to the public dialog
and yet she's you know she's you know
waved on to these shows as sort of a
conservative and Howard Washington Post
referred to as a you know a
constitutional lawyer and after she left
Capitol Hill she when she was on Capitol
Hill she was essentially a flak and
after she left she morphed into you know
legislative aide or something like that
so you know the press takes her
seriously and shame on them
she's so far out of bounds for normal
discourse Lieberman uh well it's right
your first question about Lieberman well
it's interesting I don't know who just
reading the coverage I don't know who's
more spooked about the the August
primary the Beltway press or Joe
Lieberman I mean they both seemed
absolutely panic-stricken that Ned
Lamont might win and I you know the that
narrative is interesting I mean it's
being portrayed as a purge I think most
people call it a primary but I guess
primaries are frowned upon in the
Beltway now and so everyone is
I'm actually supposed to be sent back to
Washington and if Democratic voters in
the state of Connecticut don't then it's
a sign that the Democratic Party is I
don't know it doesn't make crazy so I
don't understand it but I think I think
the mainstream press and Joe believer
and are both scooped by the influence of
the bloggers which has something to do
with I think Joe Lieberman and the
mainstream media both spooked by the
growing influence of the bloggers so
they're both sort of for their own
reasons very nervous and upset about
what's happening in Connecticut among
people you just said about the bloggers
um as a journalism student and I'm
particularly interested in the Internet
and the influence of online journalism
and you write for the Huffington Post
how do you think like what role do you
think internet plays in the situation
right now do you think it's going to
help or is it going to turn kind of the
same way well it's interesting
I mean the liberal again like you know
Ann Coulter the the conservative
blogosphere I think contributes very
little if anything I mean it's just sort
of right-wing ranting they want to you
know they want to they want Bill Keller
you know executive editor for The Times
you know charged with treason I mean
they're literally having this debate on
the right wing bloggers that they are
furious with the American media because
they will not openly pronounce their
devotion to the US government in the war
on terror that the the US media is being
neutral and and it's driving them crazy
which goes back to my earlier point that
they don't really understand journalism
or respect it but I think clearly the
the liberal blogosphere has more of the
momentum now doing much more interesting
reporting and analysis in terms of how
it affect it I think I mean
Connecticut's a good example of how it
is affecting it what I don't think it
will replace is reporting and I hope it
never does which is why I don't want to
see the New York Times shrink away I
want it to be as good and strong as it
can be because those organizations still
have the you know the most massive Reese
and we need them to be to use those
resources better and to do better
reporting but obviously you know the
blogs are increasingly setting the
agenda particularly on the Democratic
side takes me back to your why question
and you gave us a partial answer the
concern about being tagged as liberal
media and obviously on a personal level
that can be a concern because you get
dismissed and disregarded and abused but
on a corporate level I'm not sure that I
quite understand it because a lot of
these writers are associated with very
powerful corporate voices so I wonder if
you would just comment on why they would
be concerned about the liberal tag
particularly given that the White House
hates them already so what have they got
to lose right right well they have a
direct they have their access to lose
but a larger question is the corporate
ownership you know I you know the as you
say there aren't these are companies
owned by large massive multinational
organizations they're certainly not
owned by families anymore who grew up in
the journalism business - you know the
New York Times or one or two others you
know a lot of these companies journalism
is a small part of their overall earning
so you know multinational companies are
not known for their sort of liberal
renegade streak so I think you know I
think they're completely comfortable
sort of playing the go-along game with
the Republican power I think I think
that's reflected in sort of this
particularly within the Beltway this
sort of they've admiring Republican
hardball I think it has sort of
a boardroom feel to it it's sort of like
big business and less like politics and
things like that and also with the
consolidation of the media what's also
important is there are fewer and fewer
owners so there are fewer and fewer
people hiring so if you do get tagged as
being sort of outside the too liberal
too caustic there are you know career
implications when when your owner
decides they're going to downsize sure
in 2004 was Dan Mathers set up with that
information that have you seen any
broadcast on 60 minutes I I don't know
I wrote a chapter on Bush in the
National Guard and again it's mostly for
to look at how the press dealt with the
issue in 2000 which was they ignored it
and then how when it came up in 2004
because they ignored it
they spent weeks reporting on something
they didn't know they in 2004 they
talked about Bush had missed a couple
weeks of his guard duty or missed a
couple weekends I mean he was absent for
18 months but because in 2000 they
refused to ignore it ABC network news
throughout the entire 2000 campaign
never once mentioned anything about
questions surrounding George Bush's
National Guard service even though the
Boston Globe had put it on page one in
May of 2004 all on the record all on the
record interviews with his commanders
all based on his own military record
five days after the Boston Globe story
Chris Matthews sat down for a one-hour
exclusive interview with Canada Bush
never once asked him about the Boston
Globe front-page stories five days
earlier that asked raised very serious
questions about the service they
absolutely refused to touch it New York
Times refused to touch it so in 2004
when it came back they didn't they
didn't know what the original story was
obviously it all exploded in in
September with the CBS report I don't
know where the documents came from I
fault CBS for not properly
authenticating the memos
I think what's unfortunate is
TV loves a prop and they had these you
know memos they could flash on the
screen and they could be exclusive they
could have thrown those away and told
the same story they loved props and they
loved sort of the human element and
these memos were supposed to show you
know this personal frustration that one
of Bush's commanders was feeling for his
no-show status so they didn't they
didn't need those memos to tell the
central story but I you know people
wonder if you know Karl Rove was behind
it and it came from Texas and it was
sort of this very curious tale about a
meet up at the State Fair in Texas and
it was his envelope exchange I don't
know and you know I think dan Rather
publicly said he wanted to hire an
investigator and CBS wouldn't do it so
it raises another important point in
terms of double standard dan Rather
screwed up on a story that was critical
of Bush his career is over 60 minutes to
is over was pulled off the air several
senior producers at CBS longtime
producers senior executives lost their
jobs because CBS screwed up about a
story that was critical of Bush during
the campaign and if you don't think
other people see that other people in
journalism inside the beltway don't
understand the clear implications of
that I mean it doesn't get any more
clear than that I'm still looking for
some one person who was fired for
writing fraudulent Whitewater stories
during the Clinton years I mean people
want awards for doing fictional stories
about whitewater Jim two quick points to
make one is this I heard you say a lot
about polls and I don't really think
that people should be guided by polls
because just two months before Pearl
Harbor the American public was polled
about getting into war 85% said No thank
God FDR lied and manipulated us to get
into World War two otherwise we'd still
be dealing with the Nazis the other
issue is John Kerry's discharge I'm a
formula military man if anybody knows
anything about discharges when you go in
front of a naval review board to get
your discharge which is what John Kerry
did means your first discharge was not
honorable that's it folks that
be investigated thank you the the
question of polling yeah I don't think
the price should be obsessed with
polling well when I think the press
presents a Terri Schiavo story or a
cut-and-run story and picking sides
saying Republicans have this winning
hand Republicans around the offensive
Democrats are on the defensive Democrats
are in disarray I think some context is
helpful and to show well are they on the
defensive or not are do Republicans have
a winning hand with Terri Schiavo turns
out I think it was a colossal failure
and it really marked the beginning of
the end of Bush's second term first of
all I'd like to say that for those
people who value enlightened democracy I
think your book is the the only one that
comes to mind as being important today I
it really is it's fantastic career I'd
like to make a point and just see what
you have to say that yeah you're saying
you using the terms left and right and
so and I see from a different
perspective our our political system is
based on came from enlightenment and the
core of that is the individual has an
obligation to find out what's going on
and on his own his or her own make
decisions about it
and what I see today in the United
States could more much more accurately
be described as corporate feudalism the
real powers today in Washington because
of the money factor are corporations and
in the media the conglomeration of power
in too few hands few corporations again
the power rests with the corporations so
it's an illusion to believe we're really
in an enlightened democracy and how does
this relate to
well let me get try and get to it uh the
the media today is really dominated by
television most most Americans get their
information from television and is in
television more like the church during
feudal periods and the one thing at this
particular time it is a real challenge
to that corporate feudalism is the
blogosphere where individuals can make
decisions independently and and make it
known I'll leave it at that
yeah well you know sometimes I think
might you know where would we be without
the blogs I mean if you talk about this
media how badly I think the media had
performed since Bush started running for
president in 1999 up till now I mean I
mean the Downing Street memo wouldn't
exist I mean it would have gone straight
down the memory hole I mean that story
literally would not have been reported
and so they're doing an amazing service
but when you look in the larger scheme
it's still such a tiny slice of the
media pie because you're right
television absolutely dominates the
political discourse in this country one
or two more
right now there seems okay I'm sorry
thank you there's only one source of
news right now that I find that group
that takes the progressive stand and
that's truth out dot-org it is a
compendium on the internet of articles
from the Boston Globe New York Times
Wall Street Washington Post salon Tom
Paine calm their site has been
perpetually hacked for the past six
months by the vicious vituperative on
Jupiter and cultures of the world who
can write viruses and take them down is
this would you consider truth out to be
part of the blog or part of the
mainstream press oh it's not part of
mainstream place I mean it's not a block
per se because they don't exactly that's
why I want to know your distinction
between the two more of a headline
accumulator is like buzz flash and
things like that I am waiting for
Woodward and Bernstein right now to come
out of retirement I'm waiting for Dan
Rather to stand up at 75 and just do it
his arms were up for better or worse I'm
old enough to remember Nixon and men
when he went down the world was a good
place well where is everybody
but gen allows you know Dan had his
chance for Denis Dan was in it wasn't
and was deported me many times during
the Bush administration yes he you know
you're right but what about what he's
doing now well yeah I mean no no I think
I'm using and that that private net well
we'll see if you know if without the the
CBS corporate restraints whether he's
had this burning desire to really sort
of see how the truth or not where the
youngsters where's the Katie Couric set
the world well I know but you know thank
God for Mark Cuban he's got plenty of
money and we need more people with
plenty of money his famous basketball
team did okay did okay Oh everything
other things the way they pulled Dan
Rather and his team off is also similar
to do you remember they there was a very
innocuous movie about Ronald Reagan but
wasn't a hug you know wasn't leaving you
know didn't worship him CBS and it was a
nothing movie couldn't air it and the
right I think it ended every show Tommy
nobody sees ya when people watch it
there it started hey there's scratching
their heads can you imagine they pulled
that Reagan thing it just shows you the
power and how afraid they are of these
people that that is unless you write
something about Reagan then he won the
Cold War single-handedly which is
another mess well no this well yes the
problem was he was I think the script he
was bickering with his wife which was a
no no but but but that episode was two
important things it was an absolutely
the right wing went nuts and they
launched an absolute crusade which CBS
blinked which was a precursor to 2000